[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello, and thank you
for joining me today.
I'm Mine Çetinkaya-Rundel
I am a developer educator at
Posit and a professor of the
practice at Duke University.
I mainly teach statistics
and data science.
And today's agenda is teaching
the tidyverse in 2023.
I am going to talk to you
a little bit about the code base
that has changed in the
tidyverse over the last year.
And, really, when I say last
year, I mean the academic year.
And there's an accompanying blog
post to this video that
you are welcomed and encouraged to
read through for more details as well.
But before we get started
with the tidyverse,
let me start with a little
bit of a trick for you. So
this is usually what my RStudio
IDE looks like when I get
started teaching. This
is the color scheme,
the theme I prefer to use
when I am working on
my own during the day.
This is what I prefer
when I'm working at night.
And this is what I
prefer when I'm teaching.
And the way I've changed
through these different themes
is I've written a package
that has a bunch of--
like, a personal package that has
some add-ins for me so I can quickly
switch between
teaching mode and
themes that I like to use when
I am actually working on my own.
I recommend getting some shortcuts
for yourself like this as well.
So we are going to
start by loading the tidyverse and
the palmerpenguins packages that
we're going to use for
some of our data examples.
And I'm going to load two
other packages, gt and package load.
We're going to use these for just
a couple of things along the way.
The first thing I'm going to
talk about is the native pipe.
Your tidyverse pipelines may
have looked something like this
in the past.
You start with a data frame
and then you pipe that into, say,
a dplyr function, like count,
and the result looks
something like this.
Since R 4.0, you can now
use the native pipe here as well,
and you're going to get
absolutely the same answer.
So you might be wondering, why
would I want to do that? Well,
one of the nice
things about using
the native pipe is that it's
going to work even outside of
the tidyverse or outside of
loading the magrittr package as well.
So let's go ahead
and restart R.
So now none of my packages
are loaded again. And let's add
something else,
something like--
start with the mpg data frame
or maybe even mtcars data
frame. And then let's use a
base R function,
like summary().
Even though I have none of
the tidyverse packages loaded
or the magrittr package loaded,
I'm able to use the
native pipe as well.
So if you're teaching your
students with the native pipe
and teaching them to
build these tidyverse pipelines,
they can learn that workflow
and apply it beyond working
with the tidyverse as well,
should they be using
a different package,
or in a different course,
or at some other point in
their life when they're coding in R.
Coming back to the tidyverse,
one of the updates to
the tidyverse was the tidyverse
meta package itself. So
tidyverse 2.0 was released in,
I think, March of this year.
Let's go ahead and restart
our R session one more time,
and let's go ahead and
load the tidyverse package.
We can see that, in the past,
we would also have to
do something like add the lubridate--
load the lubridate
package separately,
but we don't really
have to do that anymore.
So I'm going to restart.
I'm going to show you that
when I load the tidyverse,
the lubridate package
is loaded as well.
If you have not used the
lubridate package before or
haven't taught the
lubridate package before,
let's go through its
functionality very, very briefly.
Perhaps
the most important
thing about it,
as you can tell from the name,
is that it allows you to
work with dates and times.
And these can be pesky
things to work with.
So let's go ahead
and put today's date.
This is right now a numeric
variable, as you can see.
Then I can use the
lubridate package's ymd
function. So that
stands for year, month, and
day. And it will convert that,
so it will parse that text
into a Date object for me.
This probably seems pretty
straightforward, right?
We could have
probably done this by
string parsing without the
lubridate package as well.
So let's try something else.
Let's make it a little
bit more complicated.
I'm going to put this as a
text field. So I might say
7/19/2023.
And
we can say that the class
of this new object, the new
variable we created--
whoops, I should say today_t--
is a character.
This is in the format month,
day, year. So I'm going to use
the mdy function.
And lubridate will
convert that for me to
a Date object as well. And we
can check that it does that. So
mdy(today_t)
and there we go.
Also, this is, I think, a
little bit more complex. But,
again, we could have easily
parsed this string and used the
forward slashes as delimiters.
So let's make something
even more complex.
Let's create something
like an actual text string.
And I will type
here something like,
"This video is being recorded on
19 July 2023 at 1 pm ET."
You can see that
the class of this is
a character. So how are we
going to parse the date from here?
Doing so with string
parsing would be a little
bit more complicated.
We would have to catch
that 19 July 2023 there.
That might take a bit
of knowing about regular
expressions. But what I can do
with lubridate is, I can say
this is in the order
day, month, and year.
And then there's also
an hour there as well.
And it will actually go in
and try to parse out the
date and time component
from that text string.
Now, the thing is the time
zone is incorrect. Time zones are
additionally pesky. So
you would, in this case--
let's see--
actually need to add the
time zone itself. And now we
actually have the right
time there as well.
And if I look at the class
of this object that we now created,
that is a POSIXct object.
So lubridate is pretty helpful
for dealing with pesky things
like dates and times,
and now it comes with the
core tidyverse as well.
Next, let's go back to when
we first loaded the tidyverse package.
So I am going to restart my
R session and talk a little bit
about conflict resolution.
So what do I mean by
conflict resolution? What I mean is that
when I load the tidyverse
package, you can see that there
is a new--
or updated message.
It tells me that there are
two functions in the core
tidyverse, the
filter() and lag()
functions in the dplyr package,
which masks the filter()
and lag() functions,
so the functions with the
same name in a package that is
already loaded with base R,
the stats package. This message has
been here for some time now.
But what is new in
tidyverse 2.0 is that it specifically
advertises the conflicted
package as well.
And you can always get
back to this message,
even if you're not at the
beginning of your R session,
with the tidyverse_conflicts()
function,
which will print out the
end of that message for you.
So let's go ahead and
unload that dplyr package.
So we're going to take
out the dplyr package.
And let's try to run this very
common tidyverse pipeline.
I want to take the penguins
data frame and filter it for
penguins that are Adelies.
You've probably run
into this issue before.
If you haven't ran into
this issue, kudos to you,
but your students probably
have ran into this.
What's happening here is that
the message that we get is
not that it can't find the filter()
function. It can't find the
dplyr filter() function,
but it is able to
find the stats filter() function.
And it's complaining that it
can't find this
penguins object.
Or actually,
that is probably happening
because we also haven't loaded
the palmerpenguins, so
let's go back and do that.
It is complaining that the
object species is not found,
so it's sort of not
understanding what you're
asking it to do.
The way
base R would resolve this is,
if you then load the dplyr
package, the filter()
function becomes available.
And because it's been
loaded after base R,
R
will just automatically choose
the version of the function
that was last loaded, and
things work just fine.
They work just fine
until they fail.
So if we want to be a little
bit more strict about how we go about things,
in terms of having multiple
packages loaded with the same
function names, we can leverage
the conflicted() package,
which is not in
the core tidyverse,
but it is a tidyverse package.
So I'm going to go
ahead and load that.
And once I load conflicted(),
I can no longer get away
with just using the last
loaded version of filter().
It explicitly tells me, look,
there are two packages loaded.
They both have the
filter() function in it.
Tell me which one do
you want me to use.
One option is, we can
use the colon-colon notation to say,
every time I use filter(), I
can explicitly say I want you
to use the dplyr version.
This is the sort of thing
you might see in a package
development scenario, perhaps,
where you want to be very clear
about where other functions
from other packages
are coming from.
But I think in a data analysis
scenario, this gets pretty
busy. Especially if
you're teaching R,
especially if you're teaching
dplyr for the first time,
you're probably going to have
a bunch of filter() statements.
And constantly noting them with
dplyr colon colon, while not
noting them for all the
other functions that you're teaching,
I think can get confusing
for the students.
So instead, you can
explicitly declare which
version of filter() you want to
use. And there, you can
say, I want to prefer,
in this R session going
forward, the dplyr version of
filter(). No more complaints
from the conflicted package.
And I am being very explicit
in my code about which
version I'm using.
So that was all about the
tidyverse meta package. Let's
talk a little bit about now the
improved and expanded
functionality with joins. So,
much of these came with
updates to dplyr with 1.1.0
onwards. I think as of
today, we're at 1.1.2.
So there's been
additional updates to get
the rough edges sorted.
But generally, these updates are
mainly to better align with
tools like SQL and
data.table. So we have here
a sample data frame. So
I've created an island data frame,
where I have noted the
coordinates of the centroid of
these three islands.
And what I'm going to do is,
I am going to join the
penguins data frame to this.
So I'll take the penguins data
frame and left join it to islands.
And this should be a
pipeline you're sort of familiar with.
What we've done in the past
was to use the by argument--
and then in here actually
denoted which variable from the
penguins data frame--
that's the island variable--
should match to which variable
from the islands data frame--
that's the name variable.
Instead, what we can
do now is, we can say
join_by()--
so a new function--
and I will say where island
is equal to name. So with
this new notation that
is available to you,
you can actually read this out
loud how we often read out loud
logical statements.
So double equals is something
we would read out loud as
"where x is equal to y."
So now I'm able to say take
the penguins data frame,
left join it to the
islands data frame by
where island is equal to
name. I think that, while the
previous version, the syntax, the
by syntax does not go away,
I would strongly recommend
updating your teaching
materials to use the
join_by() function.
And the thing that is
nice about that is that, one,
this reading out loud is made
so much easier and aligned with
how we read out loud
other logical statements. And number two,
when we work with the
older version of this--
so this, we know worked,
but some other versions
worked as well.
So I could also do
something like this.
And this would work as well,
just because of how
named vectors work in R.
But this wouldn't work because it
says I can't find this new
name that you're talking about.
And we also saw at the
beginning that quoting both of
these work as well.
Options are good, but sometimes
they can be confusing. So by
using the join_by() notation, we
no longer need to quote our
variable names,
which aligns much better with
other functions in the tidyverse.
Another update to join
functions is where we have
many-to-many relationships.
So I'm going to create a
few more new data frames just
so we have them in our pocket
and we can use them in
our examples. One of them is a
data frame called
three_penguins. And this has
three rows, so data on three penguins.
And we have one row per sample ID.
So imagine that you're a
scientist and you're collecting
data on these penguin samples.
So this is what my
three_penguins data frame looks like.
And then we also have--
maybe collected by another
scientist, let's say--
data on weight measurements
of these penguins.
And if you have ever done
things like collecting
weight data from animals,
you probably have done this
thing where you had to measure
at least twice. So we have
this weight_measurements data,
where for each of the
sample ID of penguins,
we have two
measurements as well.
And finally, we have one more,
data on flipper length
measurements of these penguins.
So similarly, we've done
two measurements per penguin.
So let's say we have
data from these three separate scientists
and we want to
bring them together.
First,
I'm going to start
by bringing together the three_penguins
data set with
the weight_measurements
data set.
And there's just a
one-to-many relationship,
and things just work fine.
However, when I have
many-to-many relationships--
so, remember,
those two scientists that each
take two measurements from
each of the three penguins--
if I try to
join those weight_measurements and
flipper_measurements data
frames from these two
scientists, now
I get a warning.
So I get a warning that
says that it detected many to many
relationships between x and y
that was unexpected. And at the
end of the warning, it
says, if a many-to-many relationship is
expected, you can
set relationship equal to
many-to-many. Whenever I
see a warning like this,
my first hunch is, OK, well,
let's just try what
it tells me to do.
At least it'll shut
up the warning,
but maybe it will also
be the right thing to do.
So let's go ahead and add that.
So this relationship
argument is new
with dplyr 1.1.0
onwards. And, in fact, now
we have explicitly said, yes,
we were expecting
this many-to-many relationship. However,
let's think about
this for a second.
We started with three
penguins, two measurements per penguin,
so six rows of data,
and we're bringing together
these data from these two
scientists. But
all of a sudden,
I have this explosion
of rows situation.
I have 12 rows. And 12
is not a large number,
but imagine if you had hundreds
of measurements from these
scientists. You would end up
with this explosion of rows.
So in this case, what we
actually should be doing is,
instead of denoting a
many-to-many relationship,
we might actually think back to
our data structure and say, no,
I want to join by not
just sample ID but by
measurement ID as well.
So the join_by() function
can take multiple variables,
just like the by
argument of joins can.
And the relationship argument
of the improved join functions
is great for catching
in the tracks of making
a mistake about how
you're joining data sets.
But the suggestions it gives
may not always be the right
suggestion for your use case.
So don't just blindly apply the
warnings. But instead,
think through your data
structure to see how these
should be coming together.
And I think the teaching tip
to take away from here is that
when you're introducing these
functions to the students,
I would recommend doing
something similar to what I've
done here, which
is, iteratively,
sort of fall into the traps
that you expect to fall into or
you don't expect to fall
into. Read the warnings, messages,
or errors out loud. Think
through them with them
together, and then apply
some sort of solutions
to the problem.
The explosion of rows problem
is something you have probably
come across working,
particularly,
with new learners who will
happily join any two data
frames and sometimes crash
their R session or, if
you're teaching on a teaching server,
crash the whole server. So
walking through these sorts of
examples with small data sets
where they can see
how the rows are expanding
or contracting back to what we
expect them to be, I
think, is pretty helpful.
Another
new argument is handling
unmatched cases with the
improved join function.
So I'm going to make one more
new data frame. This time,
my measurements include
one more penguin.
So I have four penguins
in my data frame.
And we're going to say
take the weight measurements from that
one scientist and left join
them to these four penguins.
It's fine. R will happily join
them for you. But, poof, that
fourth penguin is gone.
Maybe you never wanted
the fourth penguin,
and maybe this is exactly
what you wanted. But
it is likely the case that this
was a much larger data set, and
some of these unmatched
cases silently disappeared
and you never caught them.
So one option is to say, well,
I definitely don't care any of
the penguins whose weights I don't have.
So I'm going to explicitly use
an inner join to solve this
problem, not a left join--
so saying that I only want
the penguins that are common
between these two. Another
option is to actually use the
unmatched argument and
say, when I do this join,
anything that's unmatched,
explicitly drop that.
So, again,
the results we're getting from
these is exactly the same. And,
in fact, you can
also do nothing.
You can do exactly what
you did at the beginning,
but do it at your own risk.
So the difference between
using the unmatched argument or
not is basically saying that
I'm making it very explicit.
When I come back to this code,
I want to remember that I
explicitly did not care about
the other penguins whose
weights we did not have.
Another value you can use
for the unmatched argument is
actually error. So this might
be a good starting place,
where it says,
if there's any unmatched
cases, just error out.
I will stop at that point
and read through the error and then
decide what I want to do.
So the error tells me that
each row of y must be matched
with x. And in this case,
row 4 of y was not matched.
And now it's
basically telling you,
decide what you
want to do with it.
And you might go back to saying,
fine, drop that one. So the error
value for unmatched is
a great starting place,
particularly for
interactive data analysis.
And then you want to explicitly choose
one of the values and go with that.
All right, so we've talked
about joins in new dplyr.
Let's talk about one other
feature of the most recent
dplyr package, which
is per-operation grouping.
So I'm going to start with
a very typical tidyverse pipeline here.
I want to plot the mean body
weights of penguins by species and sex.
So I'm going to start with
the penguins data set.
Just for ease, I'm going
to drop any of the penguins
for which we don't have body
mass or sex information.
And then I am going to
group them by species and sex. So
I can see that this is
now a group data frame.
And then I'm going to
summarize to calculate
the mean body weight
per species and sex
of these penguins.
And then let's go ahead and
actually make a plot of this.
Now, you can see that
when I make this plot--
or even earlier when I
just did my summary--
there was a message that
got printed out. It says,
summarize() has grouped
output by species.
You can override this using
the ".groups" argument."
So this message--
which can catch
you by surprise,
particularly if you're doing something
like creating a dot plot, where
summarize() is not even
the last statement in your
data pipeline--
is basically saying that you
had grouped the data by two
variables. When we ran
summarize(), we sort of peeled
off that last
grouping variable,
but the data are still
grouped by species.
And turns out, for making
this plot, it doesn't make any
difference. So you can happily
ignore that message.
But what generally tends to
happen is that if we don't
address this issue that the
data frame is still grouped,
this can result in frustrating
situations, particularly for new learners--
but trust me, even for
experienced users--
because the data underlying
this is now remain grouping.
And sometimes this can
have downstream effects.
It didn't have
it on the ggplot,
but let's look at
a couple examples.
So here, for example,
I am grouping the data by
species and sex again. I am
going to find the mean
body weights again.
And then I want the
top row of that output.
But if I actually drop my
groups, then the top row of
that output is just one row.
So
when we have grouping that
persists through the pipeline,
certain functions will then
output slightly different results.
And if you were expecting one and
you get the other or vice versa,
it can be pretty confusing to
try to catch where did this happen.
Another example I like to
give with this is using the
wonderful gt package
for making tables.
Here, I have
data that is still
grouped after
running the
summarize() function.
So the gt package will
nicely group my output and
display this output for
me as such. However,
when I actually
explicitly drop my groups,
that grouping structure goes away.
So gt doesn't apply that
nice grouping.
Which one you want?
The idea is, you probably want
to be explicit about that.
So one of the options that we
saw is that every time you run summarize(),
you can decide what you want to
do with your groups. You can decide
drop them, which means the
remaining data frame is not grouped.
Or you can decide that you
want to assign another value to
this, like keep or
keep last, for example.
Alternatively, with new
dplyr, you have a new option,
per-operation grouping. So
you can see that in this new
pipeline, I do not have a
GROUP BY statement anymore.
I start with my data frame,
I did the dropping the NAs,
and then I said summarize
to calculate the mean body masses
for me but do that by species.
So this new .by
argument allows me to
do the grouping in the
operation where I am doing the
summarization. And the
resulting data frame is no
longer grouped. And I can
actually do this by species and
sex, like we were doing
before. And again,
the resulting data
frame is not grouped.
I didn't have to explicitly
say, once you're done with it,
drop the groups, which I
think is a slightly less
straightforward or intuitive way
of going about things.
But here, we're just
explicitly saying,
when you're summarizing,
group by these two variables.
And when you're done,
don't leave the data
frame grouped anymore.
So my recommendation would
be, I think, to consider
teaching the .by version
of this per-operation grouping,
particularly if you find that
your learners tend to
struggle with persistent grouping in
dplyr pipelines.
That being said, the new
version of R for
Data Science, which
very recently came out--
right here--
does mention the .by
argument for
per-operation grouping,
but it doesn't dwell
on it too much.
So a majority of
the presentation still uses group_by().
So you can decide based on
how strictly you want to stick to
the text or not if you
are using that text for your teaching.
All right, one
more bit on dplyr--
my most favorite function,
case_when() for some reason.
I really like that function.
So now it has gotten some
updates as well, some
quality-of-life improvements.
Let's start with this.
I'm going to calculate some
quantiles for the penguins data
set. So I have the 25th
percentile and the 75th
percentile of my data. And
using these, I want to
categorize my penguins as
small, medium, or large.
So if a penguin is less than
3,550 grams, I'm going to
label them small. If
they're between these two,
I'm going to label them medium.
And if they're
greater than 4,750,
I'm going to label them large.
And if they were NAs, I
want to leave them as NAs.
So here,
what we're seeing is this would
be a typical sort of case when--
pipeline where the last row--
or the last call says,
if it's not any of these,
then call it true. And for
those rows, label things large.
Let's also do something that
will allow us to more easily
see what's going on
in this pipeline.
Whenever I have a data frame
that's wide with lots of
columns and the columns
that I'm operating with,
I can't see when I run my
pipeline, I like moving them
up. So I probably will
want to move up here
the body mass
and the new variable that
I created, the bm_cat variable.
So let's relocate those to
move them up so that I can spot
check that my assignment is
working well. In fact, we might
temporarily pipe this to the
view() function just to make
sure that we have some
larges as well. So, indeed,
in our data frame, we do
have some larges as well.
I have personally always
found explaining why we call
this true a little
challenging when teaching case_when(). Because
you're not necessarily reading
out all the conditions.
And even if you do,
I want to say something like
if all else fails. So case_when()
has gained a new
argument called .default
that basically says, if it's
not any of those, make it
large. So now we
can achieve the same
outcome without using
the true as a catch-all
for anything that didn't match.
And finally, with dplyr,
I want to highlight what
I think is a very exciting
development with if_else(),
case_when(), and friends. So
let's say that I
have my data frame,
something like this,
and I want to create
a new variable that actually shows
the units, so the grams,
next to the values as well.
So let's say I want to
have something like this.
For each of the body masses,
I also want to have a
character value that brings together the
value and the units.
It used to be that you had
to type NA_character_ here.
Because all the other values
in that column were characters, so
now you have to introduce--
to do this very simple task of
creating a character string from a numeric--
the notion that there are
different sorts of names in R.
And I think that's a pretty
high-level thing to be
mentioning. So now you can
actually get away with calling
this NA and don't have to
worry about NA_character_ or other NA variants,
where I think they don't
necessarily belong as early in
an introductory R curriculum
as what we have here.
Next, let's leave dplyr aside and take
a bit of a detour and talk about
tidyr and, specifically,
separating columns.
So I have a new
data frame here,
data on penguins with
text string descriptions.
So maybe you have a
different scientist who,
instead of putting
things in a spreadsheet,
has put them in a Word
document or something.
And you have these
three specimens and
some descriptions about them.
And what you might want to
do is take these descriptions and
turn them into a data frame
or a spreadsheet version.
The separate() function
existed previously in
tidyr,
but it has evolved to
allow for different ways of separating.
So one option is to separate.
And we want to separate
wider because we want to
put these pieces of information in
columns that go next to
each other, as opposed to longer,
into additional rows.
We want to separate wider
this description column.
And we want the delimiter
to be the comma.
So I want something like this
for one of my variables
and something like this for my
other variable. And I'm going
to call those new variables
"species" and "island".
This gives me something,
perhaps, a bit more useful than
these descriptions, but there's
a lot of repeated information.
So if you are into that
sort of thing of writing regular expressions,
you can actually take things
one step further with a new
function called
separate_wider_regex(), where
you can actually give regular expression
patterns to it and, in one go,
result in something like a
species column and an island
column without the
repeated information.
If you are teaching
regular expressions,
I would say this
is the way to go.
If you're not teaching
regular expressions in your class--
or before you teach
regular expressions--
you could do something
like this and then use some
functions from the
stringr package, like str_remove(),
to get rid of the redundant
species and island
tags here.
Another exciting development here,
though, is something about
what happens when things
don't work out as expected.
So if you look at the
documentation for these new
separate() functions, you will see
some new arguments as well--
specifically, too_few
or too_many. So what to
do if there are too few
components? Should they be
aligned at the start,
aligned at the end,
or should just give you an error
so that you can look into it?
Or, if there are too
many of them, what to do?
Should they be dropped,
or should they be merged
with the last one?
And the debug option here
basically will print out something.
It's probably not something
you want in your final code,
but it's very helpful
for interactive use,
where you can take
a look to see what
to do and then make a
decision in terms of whether
"align_start" or "align_end"
makes more sense.
We've talked about a lot
of new, exciting updates.
So I'd like to wrap this
up by talking about something maybe a
little bit more
lighthearted. So one minor
update to ggplot2--
this is not the only
update, I think,
that has happened to ggplot2,
but one that continues to
catch me in my tracks--
is a new argument
for
changing
how your lines look,
so for line geoms.
So if I do something like this,
where I am plotting flipper
length versus body mass of penguins,
and I want an overlay a smooth
curve over it but I want that
line to be a bit thicker,
you will get a warning
that says please use linewidth
instead of size. I
do agree that linewidth indeed
seems to be more
appropriate here
in terms of what to call
that. And I've, in the past,
struggled with articulating
why it was called size.
That being said,
I will say that
the best teaching tip
I can give you is,
just check the output of
your old teaching materials
thoroughly to not make a
fool of yourself when you're
teaching to constantly see this warning
pop up at an unexpected time.
So I've tried to go through
much of the code that is in the
accompanying blog post and interactively
explain some of these updates.
I should mention and emphasize
that much of what I've talked
through are things that you
can now do optionally. And in
places where I feel like
that is an improvement in the
context of teaching, I
try to highlight those.
You could also just not
do any of these things.
Chances are none of your code
is going to fail, per se,
unless there was something
happening that was an error to
begin with that was
slipping through.
But I think that these updates
are nice to think about as we
approach the new academic year and
as you might be thinking about
what to change or what
to update in your teaching materials.
And remember that the tidyverse blog
is a great place to catch
up with all tidyverse
updates, whether teaching related or
not. There's been a lot of
other updates to the packages,
that if you dig through this
year's post, that you will see--
to stringr, to
tidyr, to forcats--
new API for the rvest package--
and also, if you also tend to
teach SQL along with your data science content,
shorter and more readable
and in some cases faster SQL
queries in dbplyr.
And I'll wrap up by saying that
the new version of R
for Data
Science is out.
And much of the updates
that I've talked about here were
sort of done in order to catch
up with what we wanted to
showcase in the book.
So you can expect the
development to slow down a
little bit as you phase
in these new changes into your
teaching materials. Thank
you very much for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING] PLAYING]